joining us right now to talk about Game
one of the World Series is a man who is
the fastest player in Phillies franchise
history to reach 30 career home runs my
kids loved watching him in the home run
derby in Washington DC this year
all-star Rhys Hoskins how are you Rhys
thanks for having me pleasure to have
you on this program right now what do
you think a game won last night reason
well two really good things obviously
there's an entertaining game but my
first impression of the game last night
is the Red Sox are really really good
the Dodgers are gonna have to score a
lot of runs to keep up with that offense
so what do you think makes them really
good reason well I mean obviously you
start with their offense right I think
you've heard the word relentless quite a
bit I think their approaches these guys
have up and down the lineup and kind of
spills over to the guys on the bench as
well as that they they grind pitchers
down you know they gotta curse all out
early in the game and then you start to
get into the bullpen but they're not
afraid to hit with two strikes they do
the little things you know you got
Mookie getting on in the first inning
and then stealing a base and all of a
sudden one batter into the gaming of a
guy in scoring position and I think like
you guys have talked about they get the
big hits and that's been pretty obvious
especially in this postseason
now it's interesting you say that you
know they they got Kershaw out of the
game and they did put two men on in the
fifth inning but to me Reese you know
again IIIi see Kershaw and I know that
you know sometimes you have an off night
and pitching coaches and managers know
that better than just me sitting on the
couch it's just beginning to drive me a
little crazy that that starters don't go
deep into games and that bull penning is
the way of the day and lefty righty
matchups rule the moment as opposed to
it seems like relying on the human
element a little bit more I'm wondering
if you as a major leaguer playing for a
manager who is a very analytics driven
individual once you think about that if
you think that's an accurate portrayal
of what's gone down in baseball right
now well I think especially in the
postseason you know I think especially
now in the World Series but
I think these managers kind of have a no
stone unturned type of mentality you
know if the matchup says that this is
the best matchup to you know sway the
game in their favor I think you kind of
have to to listen to that now obviously
like you talked about there is a little
bit of human element involved and I
think what usually tends to work the
best is a blend of the two I think last
year when the Astros won I believe I
remember AJ Hinch saying yeah there are
some decisions that arch kind of just
made it as it got a gut call and
obviously they're not working out for
them to end up to go on to win the World
Series but I think if you have a blend
of the two
usually gives you the best chance to win
and is it frustrating though playing in
not having baseball in an error like
this it can be it can be but it can also
be frustrating the opposite way as well
you know you maybe you trust your gut
sometimes and it doesn't work out for
you oh that's also frustrating so I
think both can be frustrating but I
think the information now and the amount
of information that's available can be
really really helpful resource can sear
in the Honda inside a report on the Rich
Eisen show who do you think is the best
player in the World Series right now
Reese you had to choose one I would
choose Mookie
I think Mookie Betts just can impact a
game in so many different ways you know
we saw obviously with the bat last night
on the base pass as well in the first
inning you know I think one defensive
player stands out and in this postseason
is the play that he made down the
right-field line to get Tony Kemp
now ISM game before what a seed he's
from there man right seed and you got
one of the fastest runners in baseball
with Tony Kemp in a huge situation of
the game you know obviously the biggest
game of their season any throws absolute
dart right the second base to take it
himself
Mookie's is it's hard to compete with
obviously
Martinez and the season he had was
absolutely incredible but with what
Mookie can do all over the diamond was
really really impressive well if you
could choose on either team then maybe
it's the same guy one at bat needing an
RBI needing a hit needing to knock
somebody in who would you choose in the
World Series I think I would choose JD
Martinez the consistency that he showed
you know this season especially with
guys on base I don't know the stats off
the top of my head but my guess would be
that he was one of the best hitters with
runners in scoring position and guys on
base and obviously you have the 130 RBIs
to show that so I would feel pretty good
sending him up to the plate when when my
team needed a run how tough is it
playing outfield in Fenway Park recent
yeah it's it's tough and I think you
kind of saw how uncomfortable some of
those daughter's outfielders were last
night you kind of have to get a crash
course when you get there and there's
not really a whole lot that you can
substitute for some game experience and
then you add you know the monster you
had all the things that the ball can
bounce off on the monsters then you add
then you know right field Pesky's corner
has a little niche in right-center field
there's are so many different things
that you're not used to and that are in
other ballparks that you just end up
thinking about instead of just playing
the game and letting the ability take
over Phillies left fielder Reese Hoskins
here in the Honda inside a report on the
Rich Eisen show do you get shifted a lot
do you see a lot of shifts this year
yeah from the right side yeah I did
more yeah more so in the infield I would
say the outfielder in the outfield it
was more of a shade instead of a shift
okay but yeah I mean you're seeing
you're seeing that quite a bit with wisk
guys you know there's I think the
percentage usually tends to be low and
that's why they they shift and I think
that's just kind of way the game is gone
how does it mess with your approach does
it at all it doesn't know no it doesn't
honestly my goal is not to hit the ball
in the infield if I hit the ball on the
ground I'm usually out anyways and if I
if I'm if I'm trying to hit a little
ground ball to second base well now we
need three ground ball to second base
instead of two hits or a walk in a
double so it doesn't take button doesn't
take me out of my approach at all
does it lead to more strikeouts do you
think if you see if you're saying you
know what ground balls don't do me any
good I'm gonna try and yoke this one
over their heads or out of the park do
you think that leads to more strikeouts
for you I think it can but also at the
same time I think strikeouts are up in
the game because the pitching is is what
it is it's I think pitching has evolved
quite substantially in the last couple
of years everybody throw 95 has become
the new ninety you know you get into
both ends like you say you're seeing
matchups earlier in games guys throw
harder guys have better stuff and you
still gotta score runs and because it's
becoming harder to score runs
you gotta pick and choose you know what
you think the best way to do that is
what if baseball resaw skins came up
with a rule where you had to have at
least two infielders on one side of the
base because left lefties feel that they
are being discriminated against in all
honesty they think it's biased against
lefties I've spoken to lefties I've
spoken to agents of lefties so what do
you think of that idea would you be up
for that
I think I think you're getting into a
lot of gray area that I think there's I
mean can you can you have both feet on
on one side of second base you know up
one if you start I mean how far can you
go over on the other you know that
there's just there's a lot of gray er
that then becomes judgement calls based
on the umpires and bless them bless the
umpires but their their job is pretty
hard already and I think you would just
end up having more disputes and which
would you know would lead to a lot I
think a lot of negativity around the
game he's saying that about the umpires
because
you want a better strike zone is that
what that is are you kissing up to me
you're saying there's a lot there's a
lot of gamesmanship in this game okay
you don't get you don't get to where
you've gotten right now I'm just pure
brawn you didn't gonna have the smarts
to you're gonna have the stuff as well
right there and what to what do you owe
your your early success in your career
please just talk about you a little bit
here yeah I think I was introduced to
the mental aspect of the game at an
early age you know going back to my high
school career my college career and the
importance of that and the importance of
having an approach at the plate
honestly I've talked about this before
but there was a mechanical change that I
made when I got into professional
baseball that allowed me to kind of tap
into some of the power that I have
allowed me to have some more rhythm at
the plate and quite honestly just see
pitches better and you know with that
comes confidence and confidence is a
huge thing in this game do you ever play
another sport because you know Dion
tells me all the time how baseball
helped him in football and vice versa oh
yeah
yeah I grew up playing basketball and
and football as well you just learned
how to use your body in different ways
putting body control and balance and all
that helps you and all sports okay and
you know you learn how to compete in
different situations I think you know
when you and then you end up playing
other sports or multiple sports nothing
seems to surprise you when you're on a
field of some sort is your manager the
most rocked up guy in the clubhouse
reason I would say Jake Arrieta is
probably that really arrieta's rocked up
and then then your manager Gabe's got to
be up there as well yeah very intense
intense individual it's funny too he'll
get in the weight room sometimes when
we're in there too and it's just a
unique relationship that you have with
your manager what do you mean he's
intense in the know what Kapler wants to
work in or like how does that work
what do you mean by that so he goes he
goes about his business his own way but
obviously Fitness is a big big portion
of his his life and he takes that
seriously as well okay like overly
seriously like too seriously like I mean
I don't wanna get you in trouble but
okay no no I wouldn't all right all
right very good
Rhys appreciate the time before I let
you go I know that you're you work
closely with a summer camp for muscular
dystrophy association and you hosted an
event for MDM da at Citizens Bank Park
I'd love to give you the floor on your
charitable side of your works in
Philadelphia yeah so the muscular
dystrophy association MDA for short has
been something that has been near and
dear to my and my fiance's heart since
high school it's an organization that
works predominantly with kids but adults
as well to have neuromuscular diseases I
got involved with a summer camp when I
was younger and just the candid
interactions with the kids really
touched me
and so we've stayed involved throughout
the years I did host an event at
Citizens Bank I think now for the second
year in a row just cool to kind of bring
all the kids out you know I got to get
to watch batting practice get to go on
the field we get to hang out a little
bit before the game starts and then this
offseason those there's a black and blue
ball is what they call it it's a gala
fundraiser type of event where there's a
lot of information given and a lot of
awareness spread so I'll be attending
that and I'm excited about January 18th
in Philadelphia so a lot of exciting
stuff coming up with with MDA that's
great MDA org to get involved
congratulations on your impending
nuptials then when you get married you
get a date set and I want to put any
pressure on you have the date set no
they said okay looking at some time
after the World Series next year nice
cuz you got it you got to win it right
you got to bring the
where I understand right how'd you pop
the question if you don't mind me asking
Rhys Hoskins before I let you go
ultimate insider for the insider report
brought to you by Honda what he got no
it's a I did it on the beach in San
Diego we we spent a lot of time in San
Diego growing up so the location was
somewhere that you know we used to go
okay quite a bit as as teenagers and
adults and meant a little bit to us and
I think though schools obviously sunset
ocean and got some surprise there with
me with some family as well whales
breaching and dolphins jumping right I
was beautiful is it well done yeah nice
and did you get down to Annie she do the
whole thing I did I did I did she got to
be right touch him all resource conceded
that well done well done congratulations
on that I hope this is the first of many
times we get to chat on the show really
enjoyed it oh I should ask you this last
question for I let you go do you think
the Red Sox take it then based on what
you saw last night
I do I do I think it's gonna be a great
series I think it would be really fun to
watch but my prediction is sake six okay
and do you think you see the shortstop
of the Dodgers wearing a particular
shade of red in a certain letter that
starts with P on top of that I don't
know I don't know but I certainly would
not hate to play along Ruiz take care of
yourself thanks for the thanks for the
you graduated Hoskins Philly left
fielder the Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on audience